today's Wednesday October 29th and this
is gamespot news I'm Chris waters here
to get you caught up on the latest as
our regular Australia crew gets prepped
for pax Australia presumably by packing
their Tucker bags full of hand sanitizer
and getting their neighbours to feed
their jumbuck seeeeee yes all of my
humors based in folk songs but don't
worry my news comes straight from the
source let's do it details about the
dark below the first downloadable
expansion for destiny have been revealed
so listen up my fellow Guardians here's
what's coming we're talking new gear
armors and weapons including legendaries
and exotics the light level cap is
getting bumped to 32 and you'll be able
to carry 10 bounties at a time new story
quests strikes and the new raid all
appear to focus on the crusty old hive
enemies and if you're playing on a
Playstation platform you'll get a bonus
strike thanks to Sony's wheeling and
dealing free new crucible maps round out
the dark below which is included in the
$35 season pass or available standalone
for twenty dollars on December 90 rad
only six more weeks of playing the same
missions we've been playing since launch
shifting gears to the only major console
maker without a stake in destiny things
are looking up for Nintendo despite
analysts predicting a big loss for the
company in the most recent quarter
Nintendo turned a sizable profit last
quarter thanks largely to strong global
sales of super smash brothers for 3ds
Tomodachi life has also sold very well
and even the flagging sales of the wii u
turned around more than doubling in the
past six months seems like good momentum
for the company heading into the retail
madness of the holiday season here's
hoping things continue to look up were
you looking forward to playing the
upcoming open world zombie game dying
light on your xbox 360 or Playstation 3
Q sad trombone music
developer Techland announced today that
following thorough internal testing they
concluded that they had quote no choice
but to leave past gen systems behind and
release dying light exclusively on
next-gen consoles and PC the statement
concludes put simply older consoles just
couldn't run the game and stay true to
the core vision of dying light at the
same time alas this leaves last gen
system owners only 17,000 zombie games
to play instead of seventeen thousand
and one let's finish things on a happy
note super slick trailer for halo 2
anniversary was released today so let's
roll that beautiful warthog footage oh
doh the trailer shows off the brand new
cutscenes created by blur Studios for
halo 2 anniversary which is included in
the upcoming hallo master chief
collection which releases for xbox one
on November 11 to see more of the master
chief collection in action be sure to
check out the archive of gamespot's live
stream from earlier today and be sure to
look at the grave mind because it's
super gross just like toothy slimy plant
it's it's gnarly you're gonna have to
see yourself I'm Chris waters thanks for
watching today I'll see you tomorrow for
more news chief is going to jump in this
tank roll across the bridge and blow up
any inhuman son of a [ __ ] dumb enough
to get between him and the Prophet of
regret pull yourself together because
you're going with it